hi
good afternoon
good afternoon welcome to my talk eating
an elephant conquering
large projects one bite at a time
don't worry today we're not talking
about whether or not the big bull
elephant or the baby
elephants the juiciest one or what
source is
good to use or even how best to grill it
no today it is actually a vegan friendly
talk
so it's based on
a saying from a world war ii veteran
crate neighborhoods
when eating an elephant take one bite at
a time and what he's trying to convey
here is
when we have a large complex task in
front of us just focus
on the smallest thing possible now this
saying
has many variations and one of my
personal favorites
is the journey of a thousand miles
begins with just one step
so who am i to talk to you about eating
elephants and
solving large problems hi i'm
liam elliott i'm a solution architect
and i've been a dot net developer for
over 15 years
i have been on projects that
myself very small projects of several
weeks
through to large multi-million dollar
multi-year complex
builds i used to be a consultant here at
ssw i have to
thank for lending me letting me um
record here today
and over my time i've worked across a
lot of
many different domains a lot of domains
that i actually
more domains than i can actually
remember and a lot of domains that i
have
zero experience in so
outside of work i'm a father of two
these two little monkeys keep me busy
and when
they're they're not keeping me busy i'm
a trail runner
i've actually completed the 45 kilometer
blue mountain six foot track run
four times now i've got two to go before
i get the uh
the famed six foot track belt and we'll
see if my body can hold up i'm not sure
at this stage but
i guess this comes back to to the
concept of this talk that
my journey for as a trail runner if you
hadn't told me seven or eight years ago
when i started running that i would have
completed
four six foot track marathons and i was
aiming for
six all up i would have laughed in your
face
but really each of those marathons and
that whole journey has literally been me
taking just one step at a time
and just focusing on that next step
a lot of developers i'm a home brewer
and
i'm also an amateur photographer so
the photos of elephants that you've seen
in this so far and
at the end of the clip they're actually
my own photos i took those on my um
on my honeymoon but an interesting with
my hobbies one one common thread i've
found with all my hobbies
is is a desire and a passion for getting
back to first principles so when it came
to the photography i found myself with a
fantasy digital slr
with a big memory stick and i was taking
hundreds if not thousands of photos
taking them home and then sticking them
on the computer
and never touching them again and i
had i had to slow myself down and really
wanted to work out how do i
slow down and really appreciate the art
of the photography
and for that i went back to first
principles and that is
really the genesis of my talk today
so where i want to start here is i want
to start with
why and i'm not talking about why am i
here
talking to you about eating elephants
solving problems i'm not talking to
about
why you're here at nbc sydney what i
really am talking about is the concept
of
starting with why introduced by simon
sinek
in his book and in that book it's
it's about leadership and it's about
it's about leadership and branding
but ultimately i feel that these
principles can be taken to the
when we're working on our projects and
building up our applications
so in the book simon introduces the
golden circle
first we can start with y and we really
focus on the y
then once we've discovered our y we can
start to identify the
how and once we've identified how and
we've solidified the how
finally we can actually start to focus
on what we're actually building
and to see a real-world example of this
i'm going to bring up a website that i'm
hopeful all of you have seen very
recently this is the ndcc sydney website
and what we can see in the top left hand
corner in their big their big heading
there is exactly their why
their why here is to inspire software
developers
and then how it's also quite obvious
they've brought together a
bunch of well-recognized speakers
and finally they're what well that's in
a small print
that's down at the very bottom they're
not really putting too much emphasis on
that it's all about the why
and the how and if we really want to
flip this on its head
and see what it would look like if they
focus it the other way around focusing
more on their wants
it might look like something like this
we use awesome
awesome venues we've got amazing
conferences we've got great
food at our venues but
in reality especially this year in 2020
that would have made it extremely hard
for them to pivot to the online model
which has been quite successful before
so what does that look like for me in
practice
well for that i want to go back to a
staple from my own childhood
the simpsons now in the simpsons
there's an episode there where homer
discovers that he's got
a long lost half brother anki her an
unki herb
runs a failing car company and asks
homer to
to design a brand new car for the
average everyday american man
so homer comes up with his design
and in this design he's got all his
fancy wings and bubbles so the kids keep
quiet
and the engineers take it away and they
start to
interpret what he wanted and start to
build his own things
and then they started to interpret it
and build it how they thought it should
be
and then unki herb takes the engineers
aside and says no no no
you must build it exactly how homer
wants it you must build
what homer wants and he really made them
focus on the why
lo and behold they build the homeowner
bill
the home of memorial was a failure and
it sunk the whole company
and in my life previous life as a
consultant i
used to tell my customers that my job
was to prevent the homeowner bill
my customers would ask me for specific
features and specific designs and
buttons
and and whatever else and whatever they
could desire
whatever they could think up but it was
my responsibility
as the software developer as the
implementer to really focus on
the while what they were trying to build
to prevent their homeoboob
so in practice again in practicing code
for me what does that mean well i'm
going to
start questioning one i'm going to
really start poking and prodding and
really questioning people why are you
asking me for this feature
why are you asking me to even build this
project and i might be even asking the
architects
why are we using a specific
implementation pattern why are we
why are we building these classes why
does this method exist and
really just probing and asking and
focusing on
why why why and then once we've
undercover
uncovered our why we can slowly start to
look at the how
and this how is
when we come up with our architectural
patterns our design patterns
our implementation details so these
things that we might be choosing our
monolith versus microservices or
whatever the architecture pattern is
this is where we focus on our how and
then finally
we start to look at the what we're
actually building these are the actual
artifacts that
come out of our coming out of our
day-to-day work this is the software the
code that we're actually generating
but i like to take it even further and
earlier this year
i found myself talking quite a lot about
documentation and
being asked about documentation and
trying to focus on that documentation
side of things and
what i realized was when it comes to
code commenting and writing your
documents
underneath the white i would love to see
lots of documentation about your why
because what we find is the why
is very static it rarely ever changes
it might change it might evolve but in
any changes that it makes
they're not that great that's
significant but when they do
we can easily update those documents
next we might put some documentation and
some commenting around our
how the implementation gets put together
how things plug together this is still
quite valuable
it will change over time it will change
more frequently than the y
but still it's going to be relatively um
relatively static
and then finally what and when it comes
to the what i'm not a big fan of seeing
too much documentation or even code
commenting
around what we're implementing i don't
want to see code comments that tell me
what a an algorithm is actually doing i
want to see
why the algorithm is there i want to see
why we've got a hack in place i don't
care
what it's doing or what or what has been
done
because the moment the code has been
updated
that documentation gets stale and it
gets thrown out the door and it's no
longer relevant
and stale document is what causes no end
of headaches and bugs
down the track
so
so if we've now really discovered
our why and we've really started to
narrow down our focus and question
why are we building things and why are
we doing things
we're now free to start to focus on how
things are being implemented
and for that i want to tell you a little
story about
um about my past several years ago
i started a new job and i was about this
point in my career
i was loving life it was a great job
great project
um using technologies that i absolutely
loved and i
was really really confident in what i
was doing
about two weeks after starting the team
lead walks up to me
and drops two big heavy books on my desk
domain driven designed by eric evans and
implementing demand driven design by
vaughn vernon
and then as i started to flick through
these two books
i realized that you know what i think i
was actually at this point in my career
and i wasn't measuring my level of
expertise i was measuring my level of
confidence
and in later years i've come to discover
that this is called the uh
the dunning-kruger effect and
little did i know at the time but i was
pretty much about to summon
the peak of mount stupid after reading
those books i was
very much humbled down into the valley
of despair
since then i've been on my journey up
the slope of enlightenment
and one day i do hope to get to the
plateau of sustainability
so that's my background but what i
really wanted to show is
how much of an effect that the main
driven design
had on men and
ddd itself is a very very large topic
and it would take several days to cover
so
i'm not going to go into too much detail
but dd
can be broken up into two halves we've
got the problem space and we've got the
solution space
the problem space is where we define our
problem that's identifying our core
domain the supporting domains
narrowing down on our ubiquitous
language identifying our bounded context
the solution space is the technical side
it's the entities
discovering your entities your value
types
identifying your aggregate routes
but what i want to cover is the fact
that gdd
is more than just that solution space
several projects i know and a lot of
projects that i work on we've got a
project in there called
a domain and that's where we stick all
the entities and a lot of people think
well that
there we go i've got my domain project
so therefore i'm doing dimensional
design
what i want to highlight here is that
ddd goes a lot further
than just having your implementation
details
it also goes to that problem space so
i'm going to focus on
the problem space and first thing we're
going to look at
is our core domain it's what is our main
focus
what is the bread and butter for this
project or this application
or even my company how do we
differentiate ourselves from
our competitors and ultimately it's what
is our why
we're getting back to those first
principles again and discovering
why are we building this product then we
might look at supporting domains
and i like to think of those as
basically things that we could outsource
if we need to
we might outsource those to another
department in the company we might
outsource those
outsourced to a third party it doesn't
really matter
we might even build them ourselves but
they're not part of the quartermaine
these are things that we keep that that
help support our quartermaine
now i want to get on to what i feel
is one of the most underrated aspects
of domain-driven design ubiquitous
language now yesterday's keynote with
dylan spoke a lot about language
and i think it goes to highlight how
important
having a common language is when it when
i'm working with
a domain expert so what is the
ubiquitous language
it's a common language that everyone on
the team
is and that goes for product owners
testers users customers
developers domain experts everyone on
the team understands a common language
it's consistent within the bounded
context so one term is always going to
be the same thing
and when we're inside our boundary
context that i'm going to come to in a
moment
we're sure that the terms that we're
using inside that bounded context
are consistent
liquidus language serves to remove
ambiguity
and confusion so
there's many terms especially in the
english language that are very
overloaded and very ambiguous
i mentioned the word table to a database
administrator that's a table inside
their database
but to a furniture supplier it's got
four legs and then they sell it for a
couple hundred dollars
so by being able to define our
ubiquitous language we can actually
start to clarify the meaning of these
ambiguous terms
to make sure that people
understand exactly what we mean when we
say
something within that within
our language it helps to remove
confusion
because what's happening
is sorry
i've paused i'm sorry it looks like
we've got a
delay in our
can you guys still hear me
hello you can yes okay
is the video still sharing
or is it paused you're frozen on screen
how do we rectify that
oh my videos stopped but the slides
slides are progressing but my video's
stopped is that right
that is correct yes yes okay well i'll
keep going
um can i maybe i can turn that video off
i'm sorry
how's that
camera settings
okay we've got your video back on now
let's say that the angle
and that's that's dead okay
change it
sorry about that sir
our ubiquitous language is designed to
also help
highlight the confusing terms and and
concepts within the domain
so if i am
sorry in the process of sorry
that window sorry about that
again so
in the process of discovering our
ubiquitous language we're going to have
conversations with the domain experts
and what that's going to allow us to do
is start to
talk in human terms and find out these
concepts and these ideas or these terms
that are confusing
i might start asking questions and
clarifying questions
that the domain expert thinks is just
standard standard lingo that they're
making us assumptions about their terms
identifying the ubiquitous language
helps us gain
insights and identify hidden concepts
and as we're talking to these domain
experts they've got ideas in their head
that they've built up over the last 10
15 years
to get them to a certain point that is
now to them it's as simple as
tying shoelaces or even breathing they
don't think about it
but me coming from the outside of this
point of view i'm going to ask
questions and i'm going to ask very
naive questions and
i might think i know the answer but i'm
still going to ask these questions
because it's going to make them think i
want to get that process of them
thinking about what they're what they're
trying to convey
and i want to hear the cogs turn in
their brain and really get that down
so then we've got the ubiquitous
language
and according to eric evans the
ubiquitous language
is the delimited applicability of a
particular model
and basically all that means is the
boundary within this model
can actually be applied
so across a large application we're
going to look to have
multiple models and having multiple
boundary
contexts allows us to have
many models within our large application
this means that we don't need one big
monolithic model
complicating the entire product
and conversely to that bounded context
help to identify the models that exist
in our product
so if i've got a high level context map
of the many different bounded contexts
available
i can start to only concentrate on one
model and i can start to dig
in and really understand what that model
is
trying to convey
it's consistent within the ubiquitous
language the terms that we see
inside our boundary context are
contained
within that ubiquitous language there
should be no no confusion there
shouldn't be any issues between
terms within the context and within that
ubiquitous language
and what it also allows then is to have
multiple ubiquitous dictionaries across
the entire product
now this is an interesting concept
because
i mentioned earlier that a ubiquitous
language or ubiquitous dictionary is
designed to help remove
ambiguity from terms and to help remove
confusion from our
language our vernacular but for the
large applications
we may find that there are certain terms
that actually do have different meanings
and
if we have one big model one big
bounding context covering the entire
product
then that one term gets confused as to
what it
means but if i can really maintain my
focus by
by keeping my bounded context intact i
know that when i'm talking about a table
in my database context that i mean
actually a data table
or if i'm in the furniture context or
the product context if you're talking
about a table i
know that it exactly means a piece of
furniture with four legs
so we've spoken about the ubiquitous
language the founding context i've
mentioned a couple of times
the domain model but what actually is
the domain model
and nine times out of ten in reality it
is going to be
the entities that we generate the
classes that we actually generate and
they will
almost always be inside a class or a
project that we call
domain but it could be uml diagrams and
it could be class diagrams that we
pass between the teams to make sure that
the model
is is available to everyone
but what we like to think of the domain
model is that it's the heart of our
software it's what we're actually
building
everything we build around it all the
other classes all the other services
are there to serve the domain model
they're there to make sure that that
domain model is actually
up and running and it's doing what it
needs to do
it is the distilled knowledge of the
domain experts
so as i mentioned earlier our domain
experts are experts because they've been
doing this for probably 10 15 years or
more
they've studied but they know what
they're talking about and their domain
is probably extremely
complex and if i try and get all that
into
one piece of software and one model
one it's going to take me many many
years to do that two
the software is going to be overly
complicated and overly complex
and what i really want to achieve here
is by distilling it down
i just want to grab the parts of the
domain that are actually relevant
to solving my problem at hand
again it's coherent with the ubiquitous
language the terms
inside of our domain model we should be
seeing coming up
in in our ubiquitous language and pretty
much all the terms in the ubiquitous
language
should exist within our model it'll be
that
as classes as properties as methods
these ideas and these concepts within
the ubiquitous language
should appear within our domain model
and because we've simplified our our
domain experts knowledge
because we've got it coherent to this
model to this
language that we've all agreed upon
our model should be pretty easily
understandable i should be able to give
that to
almost anyone on the team the the domain
experts the product owner
the testers i should be able to show
them my model and they should really
be able to understand what's what's
being done and be able to follow through
with
with how it works
so how would this go into practice how
would i actually go about building up my
model
well first up i'm going to start to
identify the core domain the very first
step i want to do is identify my core
domain
again i'm going to focus on my why
clarify the focus of the product
and really just get back to those first
principles of why
are we building this product what makes
our product
so special compared to everyone else
then i'm going to have a look at making
a high-level context map so i'm going to
take a very high level view and start to
identify the various bounded contexts
within my domain
and within my project scope what this
will allow me to do is without getting
too bogged down into the details i can
start
to look at and plan how things start to
to glue together and i can start to
identify my integrations
how do the various bounded contexts
communicate what are their
integration points what are the
integration points to the supporting
domains
that either we develop or we outsource
and at this point i'm going to work on
one bounded context i'm going to
start to really consult with my domain
experts
and by consulting with the domain
experts i don't mean
sending them emails and hitting them up
on teams i mean jumping on a phone call
and talking to them and having
conversations
questioning and and i i guess the
initial
consultation the whole point of that
consultation is to really start to work
on our ubiquitous dictionary
start to really document down and i
physically i actually go down and
document you know wiki page or in a
markdown file start to build up your
dictionary
and question your domain expert when
they mention
industry specific terms even if you
think you know the
what the meaning is question them get
them to really commit to
a meaning for it during this
conversation
i'm going to start to identify my high
level concepts and i might start taking
notes
around various ideas that they say and
at the same time i'm going to start
writing out some high level requirements
so nothing too formal but just some high
level requirements that we might be able
to get the domain
expert to agree upon then
the next step i'd like to do when i want
to start to implement it i'm going to
start to look for a tdd approach
and what this allows me to do is start
with those
high level requirements we've put in
place and i can wrap some unit tests
around it
and then i can start to build up my
model to make sure it adheres to those
unit tests
and what that does for me is
it allows me to make sure that my model
is focused on the consumer first we're
looking at it outside in
i'm building things up from someone
consuming my model as opposed to
from the inside out where i'm making
assumptions about how someone might
actually want to integrate with my model
i'm going to focus on the shape and the
behavior so i'm going to look at
the entities and the properties and the
methods that exist within that model
and this allows me to really stress test
the ubiquitous language and really put
it to the test and make sure that
there's no ambiguity there's nothing
that's
that's an overloaded term that i'm not
quite sure about
and at this point when it comes to
actually getting those tests to pass
i'm not going to spend any time putting
in really complex logic
i'm just going to go in and do what i
like to think of my
dumb smart approach i'm going to put in
mocked out data
and i'm going to have candle responses
and
if someone's if if i've got a method
that says
adding 1 plus 1 i'm going to return 2
always i'm not going to
worry about the calculations i'm just
going to throw those results
straight out what that allows for is
just rapid development of our model
from here we can start to identify those
supporting domains so going back to the
context map we created earlier
we can start to look at the integration
points for the bounded context that i'm
working on
that model that i'm working on and i can
start to see
who's who's pulling on it who's trying
to integrate with me
and because i've got those mocked out
data
we can start to get those integrations
working super quickly
and at this point there's a good chance
we're going to go back to the demand
expert we're going to start this
iterative cycle of consulting with the
domain expert
as i said earlier this is not emails
this is not instant messaging this is
getting on the phone
jumping into a meeting and really having
a conversation about
our understanding where we're at with
the model updating our ubiquitous
language updating our concepts
adding more ideas to our requirements
and really starting to work
with them in building up
the building up the solidity of that
model
and so how does this process look in
practice
so for this i want to use an example of
a car design firm
and as someone who doesn't have any
experience in the world of
modelling cars or i'm a mechanical
engineer i don't have any experience at
all
in the domain of cars sure i use cars i
get i have an idea about them
but i'm not an expert so i might walk up
to the mechanical engineer and say look
can you tell me about your braking
systems
and they might turn to me and say well
you know there's discs at each wheel and
when the driver presses the pedal the
car just slows down and then it comes to
a stop
you know there's not a lot i can do with
that but what i can do is start
asking those questions i might ask
something that i almost think is obvious
and say well
do they have to have discs could it be
anything else
and then the mechanical engineer might
start to realize well
sure we've got drum brakes that we can
have air brakes i guess
there's many different types of brakes
and we can start to dig in deeper
and start to really ask questions about
those different types of
of models i might ask something that i
think is pretty obvious but i'm still
going to ask it
well do they have to be at the wheels
you know
can we have the brakes anywhere else why
they have to be at the wheels
what i want to do here is really just
see the motions that the and hear the
motions that that domain expert
goes through in trying to justify this
and really
i'm trying to get these concepts out of
his head
and really make him think about it and
understand that these concepts
could be just some hidden ideas
that we need to to surface within that
model
and again i might ask well does it only
have to be one per model
one per wheel what about well does the
driver have to
press a pedal is there any other way
that we can activate the brakes
and then they might turn around and say
well the the accident avoidance system
and the cruise control systems
actually can slow the car down
and then i'm thinking well great now
we've got integration points
i might ask well how does the message
get from the driver's pedal
to the disks and then we can have a
conversation around
the the the brake lines the master
cylinders the hydraulic system
or he might turn around and say well you
could do it that way or we could have
break by wire
i don't know like there's many different
ways and again there's a whole stream of
conversation we can have
around those aspects
and then finally i might ask well are
there any other systems that the brakes
connect to you've mentioned
the cruise control you've mentioned the
accent avoidance but is there anything
else
and really what we're trying to do is
identify all those
various integration points
so that's at a higher level of how i
like to tackle my domain driven design
and if we've covered off the y
we've really focused down on that why
we've really narrowed down and
identified
how we're going to build that product i
guess now's a great time to start
looking at
what we're actually going to build
and for that i'm sure a lot of people
can are familiar with the term of the
mvp
the minimum viable product the mvp
as introduced uh in the lean startup by
eric ruriz
is basically the simplest experiment we
can run
to gain validated learning and what that
means is that
we might have an assumption about
customer needs and
customer demands but it's just an
assumption
let's hypothesize let's write an
experiment and let's
identify ways that we can actually test
out these assumptions
these hypotheses and see
exactly and really start to get
validation as to whether or not these
are correct
we can adapt and we can evolve and
change our product as
we run more experiments
so i've got this image here that's made
the rounds
around the internet by henry nyberg
which shows two different ways people
might consider tackling
an mvp and he says the top way is the
wrong way the bottom way
is the right way so the differences i
find between the two
is obviously in the top one we don't get
a usable product
until the very end of our release cycle
and the second one we actually do get a
a deliverable product at each point that
we can put in front of the customer and
we can start to
start to get them to use it and get
their feedback on them
in the first one we can identify
customers needs and demands
based on the feature that we're
currently working on
but in the second one we're going to get
that feedback across the product space
as a whole
and finally one of the big differences i
find is
in the bottom one or in the top one
there's a good chance that the previous
features that we've worked on we're
going to carry those through and
we're going to move those through the
pipeline and they're going to be
available within our finished product
whereas the second one
there's a good chance that the work that
we're working on today
is going to get thrown out over the next
couple of days or the next iteration
and we're going to start again we're
going to use those learnings but the
actual products that we're building
we're going to throw them out and start
again
now this diagram has been debated
there's a lot of debates online about it
and i know in my past in my history i
always thought that this
seemed a bit backwards and i'd much
rather
i'd be more happier if it was the other
way around
but what i've come to realize is
that i think that's because of my bias
is coming from
the an enterprise developer from the
enterprise space
so if we think back to the purpose of me
that bottom purpose of
identifying customer needs identifying
customer demand
and really just clarifying with the
customer what they want
but from an enterprise point of view if
i'm working on a project
there's a good chance that the business
that's asked me to come in or i'm
working for
already has their customer be internal
or external
defined they know there's a demand for
it we're generally going to be
replacing a legacy system or building or
digitizing
a a process and optimizing processes
and what i found was that
nine times out of ten i'm not really
running experiments to identify what my
customers need
i'm really running experiments to
identify what features and how they want
their features to run
and so that's why i personally always
felt that this was not
the right way around but i sure i can
understand exactly why it's built that
way
but what i find is that there's
something missing in this diagram
in case you haven't followed in the
common theme here
it's for me it's missing the why why are
we building this product
sure that bottom one is to help identify
the customer's need
so help identify that why bit
but really if i have a business
approaching me
and they ask me to build them a mode of
transport to get from a to b
sure that bottom line might actually be
relevant but if
i was clarifying the wine to start with
and i start kept
probing the questions well what is what
is a
and where is b what distances are we
talking about i actually said well
really we want to get our motor
transport to get between sydney and
melbourne
if i walked in with a skateboard they're
going to laugh me out the door and say
hey thanks for coming let's find someone
else to get the job
done so really
what i find that's missing here is
context we really need to identify why
but it just doesn't end there because i
think there's a third approach that we
can look at for an mvp
that's a platform based mbp
and what i feel here is well if i'm
doing a platform-based mvp
i can start to start on one side at the
less scalable side
so it might be a bit more expensive and
if we take the analogy of the car
factory again
i might start building a very expensive
custom bespoke car
very low numbers but quite expensive
and what i'm doing here is proving that
we can build cars i'm proving that my
processes and my practices and what i'm
doing
can actually produce a car once i've
done that and i've proven that that
happens on those
low numbers i can start to
optimize my processes and i can start to
tweak my systems a bit and start to get
my production lines up and running
and we can start to increase our numbers
reduce our costs and increase those
numbers and then
we learn those lessons we can evolve our
platform
we can move it forward one step at a
time eventually coming up with
the high numbers and a very low cost car
and in fact this was the model that was
used by tesla
so they started out with the roadster
very expensive very low numbers
then they went to the model s which was
cheaper and not as many but
sorry there was more more model s's than
there were roadsters and a bit cheaper
then they went to the x and the y again
we've got
more numbers and still price coming down
and then finally they reduce and they
they release the model 3 which was their
very very low cost and high numbered
high-yield car now admittedly
there's well-documented issues that
tesla had with their production lines
and their productions
of the model 3 but
i'd almost bet that the problems they
had
producing the model 3 would have been
10 times worse had they ever tackled
that prop that
problem space at the very beginning they
didn't have the experience
of the roads to the s the x and the y
they wouldn't have been
able to even get anywhere near getting
their model 3 out the door
so from my point of view
what does a platform-based mvp look like
first up i really want to prove my
platform i want to
prove that everything that we're working
on is actually going to do
what i wanted to do
so what that means for me is one of the
first things i like to do is implement
what
i consider boilerplate or what a lot of
people might consider
boilerplate stuff working on your ci cd
pipeline getting your authentication and
your logging and your tracing done all
in place
because getting it done at the beginning
when i've got an empty clean slate
is going to be a lot easier than it will
be to get it done
down the track if i've got a if
if i wait several months or years to
actually start to
implement these things or several
features down the track to implement my
authentication of my blogging
i've got a lot of legacy code that i
actually need to start getting
these in place but i don't have my cicd
pipelines up and running
implementing them down the track is
going to be a lot harder than
implementing them
now and evolving them as my needs change
likewise i really want to test out my
deployments
i want to ensure that that i can deploy
my my micro services over to microsoft
business environment
i want to ensure that i can deploy these
services independently make sure that
they're not
tightly coupled make sure that i can
have
one service independently developed
updating their versions changing their
model building things up one service
without the other
i don't want to see to if we don't test
these deployments early on
when i've got a half a dozen to a dozen
or more microsurface
services in play it's going to be a lot
harder to actually get these things down
it's going to be so much easier to do it
at day one we can start to test out
our blue green deployments we can test
our failure scenarios let's
let's really stress test all these
things early on
because like i could keep saying if we
leave it down the track
it's just going to be so much more
difficult
to actually get through and on that
we're going to start to
really test out our microservices
well we're going to test out our
architecture i should say so if we're
going a monolith or microservices
i want to make sure that it does work i
want to make sure that what we're
proposing actually
builds and works if we're using some
kind of pub sub or cpqrs system or event
sourcing
or however we're going to build it i
really want to make sure that those
patterns and those
practices are in place at the very
beginning
again these things are hard to do when
we've got
too many too much legacy built
into our platform
and finally i want to talk about
integrations i want to start
testing out these integration points i
want to make sure that third parties can
communicate to me or i can communicate
to those other third parties
and make sure that the
platform again the platform i'm building
actually survives
and it works how it's meant to work now
i'm not talking about i'm not proposing
here that we don't do any form of
features for the clients and any nice
fancy ui and getting things out for the
clients right
straight away i mean that's always great
because
they love seeing that stuff and that's
what keeps the checks coming in
but we also want to make sure that we're
not throwing out
throwing all the architectural stuff and
the platform stuff out the door
and making sure that we're really just
focusing
on building our platform
so
i think now's good time to do a recap
and so where did we start we started
with starting with why
i really like to really focus on that
because one thing i don't want to create
the homo mobile
and i don't want to create style
documentation
it helps us maintain focus it helps us
get back to those first principles
of why we're actually building this
product we don't want to get distracted
by
by the overall big picture we just want
to maintain that focus
we're looking at the how i like to focus
on domain driven design model
i want to break apart my greater big
picture
and really focus on the individual
contexts the individual domains and sub
domains
and really start to identify how
the whole project goes together and
maintaining that the domain model is the
heart of my
software i want to make sure that
everything else is superfluous
everything else is there to just
support my domain and
as i said earlier i think one of the
most underrated artifacts of ddd
is the ubiquitous language we really
need to focus on that one language
have that dictionary in place that
everyone can refer back to
and then finally we start to look at
what
what are we going to build what does our
mvp actually look like
i personally i love the idea of focusing
on our platform i just want to make sure
that my
platform does what it needs to do i'm
going to maintain my focus i don't
want to build a skateboard if i'm
working for a car design firm we need to
make sure
that our mvp is
is um we don't want to lose sight of
that big picture we want to make sure
our
mep stays on focus and when it comes to
the mvp
i just want to make sure we all remember
your why
and so here's just a few resources that
i've used
over my career starting with why science
demand driven design implementing the
domain driven design
and the lean startup
thank you
does anyone have any questions
you